So for weeks and months and years, people write to their legislators, and lobbyists make massive campaign contributions to try to swing the votes. And there are stories on the TV and editorials in the newspapers. And people talk about it, and then they ignore it. Then they talk about it some more. And then there are votes, and there are compromises and more votes. And finally, the president signs the bill into law. And when he does it, there are special pens that he uses.
几周、几个月甚至几年过去了，人们写信给立法者，游说者们进行巨额竞选捐款，试图左右投票结果。电视上有相关报道，报纸上有社论，人们谈论着这一切，然后又将其抛之脑后。接着，他们又更多地谈论此事。随后是投票、妥协，再投票。最终，总统签署法案使其成为法律。而在他签署时，他会使用特制的钢笔。
It's the pens that I want to talk about. He uses more than one, then he gives the pens away. And people save these pens for years. Pens. They didn't do anything. You know what I'm talking about here? The pen that Lyndon Johnson used to sign the Voting Rights Act-- that pen did not give anybody the right to vote. It took the entire political machinery of a huge country to do that.
我想谈谈这些钢笔。他用的不止一支，签完后他会把笔送人。人们会把这些笔珍藏多年。笔。它们什么都没做。你知道我在说什么吗？林登·约翰逊签署《选举权法案》时用的那支笔——那支笔并没有赋予任何人投票权。是一个庞大国家的整个政治机器完成了这件事。
But, OK. Let's say that you end up with one of these pens. I'm guessing that, from time to time, what you do is that you take out the pen and you stare at it, and you think a thought that goes along the lines of-- this pen was right there. This pen has done something more important than I will ever do, which is, of course, a distressing thought because, after all, it is just a pen, and you are a human being. But put that aside.
不过，好吧。假设你最终得到了一支这样的笔。我猜你时不时会把笔拿出来盯着看，脑子里会闪过这样的念头：这支笔曾经就在现场。这支笔做过比我所能做的任何事情都重要得多的事。当然，这是一个让人沮丧的想法，毕竟，它只是一支笔，而你是一个活生生的人。但先别管这个。
It's just uncanny. I think that's the word. It's uncanny when something so small, for a moment, for the length of time that it takes to sign a name, can carry the entire weight of history of a nation. Today's radio program is about something small like that that was at the epicenter of a massive social change in our country for a brief moment. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这简直不可思议。我想应该是这个词。当一件如此微小的东西，在片刻之间，在签署名字所需的那点时间内，承载起一个国家整个历史的重量时，这真是不可思议。今天的广播节目讲的就是这样一件微小的事，它在某一短暂瞬间，处于我国一场巨大社会变革的震中。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today, we are devoting our entire show to this one killer story about something very small, something small that helped change something very, very large. It's a story of doctors, of science, of homosexuals, of lucky coincidence and political action, and of the sheer power of good old-fashioned face-to-face schmoozing. Alix Spiegel tells the story.
今天，我们将整个节目献给这个关于微小事物的重磅故事，正是这个微小事物帮助改变了一些非常、非常巨大的东西。这是一个关于医生、科学、同性恋者、幸运的巧合、政治行动，以及老派面对面社交强大力量的故事。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）将讲述这个故事。
This is the story of a definition, three single sentences composed of 81 words. It's the story of how this particular definition became another definition, nine sentences, composed of 237 words.
这是一个关于定义的故事，三个单句，共81个词。这是一个关于这个特定的定义如何变成另一个定义的故事，九个句子，共237个词。
Now according to some parties, this change from 81 words to 237 words liberated an entire category of humanity. According to other parties, it undermined the basic family unit, compromised the scientific authority of psychiatry, and quote, "tampered with the basic code and concept of life."
根据某些人的说法，从81个词到237个词的这一转变，解放了整个人类群体。而根据其他人的说法，这动摇了基本的家庭单位，损害了精神病学的科学权威，甚至引用称，“篡改了生命的基本准则和概念”。
Now, I should tell you that I know this story not because I read it in a book or learned it in any class, but because it's one of those stories that my family uses to explain itself. Like most family stories-- anyway, like most stories told in my family-- the version I heard growing up was an exaggeration, the relevant family member cast as a conquering hero. The actual story, the story I hope to tell you is, of course, much more complicated. But I'm getting ahead of myself.
现在，我应该告诉你，我知道这个故事不是因为我在书里读过或者在课堂上学过，而是因为这是我的家庭用来解释自身的故事之一。像大多数家庭故事一样——总之，像我家讲述的大多数故事一样——我从小听到的版本是一种夸大，相关的家庭成员被塑造成了征服英雄。真实的故事，我希望告诉你的故事，当然要复杂得多。但我有点操之过急了。
June 23rd, 1980, at the home of the seagulls in Woodstock, New York.
1980年6月23日，位于纽约伍德斯托克的“海鸥”家中。
My grandfather, John P. Spiegel, used to say that he was a fish. It's true. Most of my memories of him are memories of a body floating face down in the water, slack, communing with his brothers and sisters of the sea. He was a strange man-- a doctor of psychiatry who spent months in the desert studying exotic tribes, smoking their drugs, sleeping under the stars, living, he said, like a native.
我的祖父约翰·P·斯皮格尔曾说他是一条鱼。这是真的。我对他大部分的记忆是一个身体脸朝下漂浮在水中的样子，松弛着，与他海里的兄弟姐妹们进行着交流。他是一个奇怪的人——一位精神病学医生，曾在沙漠中花费数月研究奇异的部落，抽他们的烟，睡在星空下，按照他的说法，像个土著一样生活。
This tape, the tape that you hear running under my voice, was recorded for my cousin Zoe's 12th birthday. She'd gotten a tape recorder as a present and had asked my grandfather if she could interview him. Zoe was a smart kid, but still only a graduate of the seventh grade, and so my grandfather politely declined. He decided there was only one person present with the intelligence and experience necessary to interview Dr. John P. Siegel. That person? Dr. John P. Siegel.
这段录音，也就是你现在在我声音背景下听到的这段，是为了我表妹佐伊的12岁生日录制的。她收到了一台录音机作为礼物，并问我的祖父是否可以采访他。佐伊是个聪明的孩子，但毕竟只是个七年级的毕业生，所以我的祖父礼貌地拒绝了。他认为现场只有一个人拥有采访约翰·P·斯皮格尔医生的智慧和经验。那个人是谁？约翰·P·斯皮格尔医生。
All right, Grandpa, would you mind telling us what you're doing here?
好了，爷爷，你介意告诉我们你在这里做什么吗？
All right, John, I'll tell you. I'm here to help celebrate Zoe's 12th birthday. True, her birthday was on Thursday, but I wasn't able to be here on Thursday, so I came on Friday. And I've been here all weekend, and we're having a marvelous time.
好的，约翰，我告诉你。我来这里是为了庆祝佐伊的12岁生日。虽然她的生日是周四，但我周四没能来，所以我是周五来的。我在这里待了整个周末，我们过得非常愉快。
My grandfather interrogates himself about the difficulty of travel from Boston to upstate New York and the movie the family saw the night before, Urban Cowboy, which included an actor that my grandfather refers to as John Revolta. Then he moves on to other topics of potential interest to posterity.
我的祖父盘问自己关于从波士顿到纽约州北部的行程难度，以及家人前一晚看的电影《都市牛仔》，其中包含了一位我祖父称为“约翰·雷沃塔”的演员。然后，他转向了其他可能引起后人兴趣的话题。
And what are your plans from here on out, grandpa?
那么，爷爷，从这里开始你有什么打算？
Well, John, I'm going to go to Ireland. I've been asked to testify in a trial being conducted by a gay activist who happens to be a professor of English at Trinity College and who is bringing a suit against the state of Ireland to change the constitution, which has several extremely repressive provisions forbidding, and condemning, and devaluing homosexuality. And I've been asked to testify as an expert in mental health.
嗯，约翰，我要去爱尔兰。我受邀去作证，那是一场由一位同性恋活动家进行的审判。他恰好是圣三一学院的一名英语教授，正在起诉爱尔兰政府以修改宪法，该宪法有几项极其压迫性的条款，禁止、谴责和贬低同性恋。我被要求以心理健康专家的身份出庭作证。
My grandfather was a psychiatrist, but not in any sense an expert on what was then called sexual deviance. Still, he was asked to testify about the mental health of homosexuals and the mental health effects of discrimination against homosexuals in Ireland, in Texas, in Maine, in front of Congress, and too many places to mention.
我的祖父是一名精神科医生，但在当时所谓的“性偏离”方面，他绝非专家。尽管如此，他还是被要求在爱尔兰、得克萨斯、缅因州以及国会面前，就同性恋者的心理健康以及歧视对同性恋者的心理健康影响进行作证，这些地方多到数不清。
He was asked because, in 1973, he happened to be president-elect of the American Psychiatric Association when the organization decided that homosexuality was not a mental disease. Up until that time, psychiatrists had always thought of homosexuality as a pathology-- a problem so profound it affected, as one psychiatrist told me, the total personality.
之所以找他，是因为1973年，当美国精神病学协会决定同性恋不是一种精神疾病时，他恰好是候任主席。在那之前，精神科医生一直认为同性恋是一种病理状态——一种严重到影响整个个性的问题，正如一位精神科医生对我所说的那样。
Now, because psychiatrists believed that homosexuals were pathological, it gave scientific sanction for the rest of the country to see it the same way. Gays were routinely fired from teaching jobs, denied security clearances and US citizenship. For that matter, they were barred from practicing psychiatry, because you don't let someone who's pathological practice medicine on other people who are pathological. Or anyway, that's what the psychiatrists thought.
由于精神科医生认为同性恋者患有病理，这为全国其他人以同样的方式看待同性恋提供了科学支持。同性恋者经常因工作被解雇，被拒绝安全许可和美国公民身份。不仅如此，他们还被禁止从事精神病学工作，因为你不能让一个有病理的人去给其他有病理的人看病。总之，精神科医生就是这么想的。
That's what it said in the bible of their profession, what the psychiatrists called the DSM, or the Diagnostic and Statistics Manual, a book which listed in clear, clinical language every possible permutation of psychosis, every variant of paranoia, every deviant mental tick that the children of Freud had ever encountered, all nicely bound together under an industrial yellow cover with an authoritative OED staid font.
这就是他们职业圣经里所写的，精神科医生称之为DSM，即《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》，这本书用清晰、临床的语言列出了精神病的每一种变体、偏执狂的每一种变体，以及弗洛伊德的孩子们曾遇到的每一种离经叛道的精神症状，所有这些都被装订在一个工业黄色的封皮下，并使用了权威的OED（牛津英语词典）字体。
There it was, diagnosis number 302.0, 3 sentences, composed of 81 words, which certified homosexuality as sick.
就在那里，诊断编号302.0，三个句子，由81个词组成，证实了同性恋是有病的。
Do you look forward, Grandpa, to this engagement that you're going to have in Ireland?
爷爷，你期待这次在爱尔兰的行程吗？
Well, John, I have mixed feelings about it. It's going to be fun to spend a few days in Dublin. But it's also kind of anxiety-making because the trial is going to be held in the high court, and I'm going to be cross-examined, which I don't particularly look forward to.
嗯，约翰，我心情很复杂。在都柏林待几天会很有趣。但这也让人感到焦虑，因为审判将在高等法院举行，我将接受盘问，这不是我特别期待的事情。
If you have anxiety about doing it, Grandpa, then how come you're going?
爷爷，如果你对此感到焦虑，那你为什么要参加呢？
Well, you see, John, it isn't so often that a person has an opportunity to help to change the constitution of an entire nation.
嗯，你看，约翰，一个人有机会帮助改变一个国家的宪法，这种机会并不常有。
To hear my family tell it, it was my grandfather alone who banished those 81 words from the DSM. When I was young, the family legend was that my grandfather, president of the American Psychiatric Association, single-handedly changed the DSM because he was a big hearted visionary, a man unfettered by prejudice who worked on behalf of the downtrodden.
听我家人的讲述，似乎是我祖父一个人将那81个词从DSM中剔除了。我年轻时，家族的传说是我的祖父，作为美国精神病学协会的主席，单枪匹马地改变了DSM，因为他是一位心胸开阔的远见者，一个不受偏见束缚并为受压迫者工作的人。
This story was wrong on two counts. A, my grandfather was not president of the American Psychiatric Association in 1973-- he was president-elect. B, he didn't single-handedly change anything.
这个故事在两点上是错误的：A，我祖父在1973年不是美国精神病学协会的主席，他是候任主席；B，他并没有单枪匹马改变任何事情。
But never mind, because this version of events was discarded, anyway-- discarded after the family went on vacation to the Bahamas to celebrate my grandfather's 70th birthday. I remember it well, remember the plane, and the drive from the airport, and arriving and discovering that the hotel had a swimming pool installed about 50 feet away from the beach. I remember thinking that a pool so close to the water was both ridiculously decadent and somehow incredibly exciting.
但没关系，因为这个版本的事件无论如何都被丢弃了——在全家人去巴哈马度假庆祝祖父70岁生日后。我记得很清楚，记得那架飞机，从机场开车的过程，到达后发现酒店有一个游泳池，距离海滩只有约50英尺。我记得当时想，一个离水这么近的游泳池既荒谬地颓废，又不知为何让人兴奋不已。
I also remember my grandfather stepping out of his beachfront bungalow on that first day, followed by a small, well-built man, a man that later, during dinner, my grandfather introduced to a shocked family as his lover, David.
我还记得第一天祖父走出他的海滨平房，身后跟着一个身材矮小、结实的男人，后来在晚餐时，祖父向震惊的家人介绍那是他的爱人，大卫。
David was the first of a long line of very young men that my grandfather took up with after my grandmother's death. It turned out that my grandfather had had gay lovers throughout his life, had even told his wife-to-be that he was homosexual two weeks before their wedding.
大卫是我祖父在祖母去世后结交的一长串非常年轻的男人中的第一个。原来我的祖父一生中一直有同性恋人，甚至在婚礼前两周就告诉了他未来的妻子他是同性恋。
And so, in 1981, the story that my family told about the definition in the DSM changed dramatically. My grandfather was no longer seen as a purely enlightened visionary, but as a closeted homosexual with a very particular agenda.
于是，到了1981年，我家讲述的关于DSM中那个定义的版本发生了巨大的变化。我祖父不再被视为一个纯粹开明的远见者，而是一个有着非常特殊议程的隐秘同性恋者。
In actual fact, this version of the story also bears only a passing resemblance to the truth. The real story is, as I said, much more complicated. And though it ends in the same place as my family's version, with a world in which it's just a little bit easier for men like my grandfather to come out to their families and friends before they're, say, 70 years old, it's a story in which my grandfather really plays a pretty minor role.
事实上，这个版本的故事也只与真相有片面之缘。正如我所说，真实的故事要复杂得多。虽然它和我们家族的版本一样，最终通向了一个世界，在这个世界里，像我祖父这样的男人在他们比如70岁之前向家人和朋友出柜变得容易了一些，但这确实是一个我祖父只扮演了非常小角色的故事。
Well, Grandpa, why don't you tell us a little bit about the past?
好吧，爷爷，你为什么不跟我们讲讲过去的事情呢？
Now, John, you know that that's an extremely broad area. As an expert interviewer, you should know better than to ask me a question like that. Would you mind making it more specific?
约翰，你知道那是一个极其宽泛的领域。作为一名专业采访者，你应该知道最好不要问我这样的问题。你介意把它讲得更具体一点吗？
You're right, Grandpa. That was a very pertinent observation. Why don't you begin talking about your past and pick up--
你说得对，爷爷。那是一个非常贴切的观察。你为什么不从你的过去开始讲，然后接上——
Let's begin with a little background so the full meaning of what transpired can be properly understood. Throughout the '40s, '50s, and early '60s, the American Psychiatric Association was a very conservative place, an organization run by what were described to me by a former APA president as businessmen psychiatrists-- well-meaning, gray-haired, '50s-style professionals.
让我们从一些背景开始，以便正确理解所发生事情的全部意义。在40年代、50年代和60年代初，美国精神病学协会是一个非常保守的地方，是一个由我的一位前APA主席描述为“商业型精神科医生”的人所管理的组织——善意、灰发、50年代风格的专业人士。
Now, when the '60s arrived, these men weren't particularly interested in weighing in on the issues of the day-- on Kent State, or civil rights, Vietnam. Then a relatively small group of homosexual activists started making noise about their designation in the DSM. Specifically, the activists rejected the idea that they needed to be cured of their desire. They said that they only needed the stigma of insanity to be removed from homosexuality so that they could get jobs teaching children or practicing psychiatry-- basically, so that they could finally achieve equal rights.
60年代到来时，这些人对参与当下的议题——肯特州立大学枪击案、民权运动、越南战争——并没有太大兴趣。然后，一小群同性恋活动家开始就他们在DSM中的定性发出声音。具体来说，活动家们拒绝了他们需要治愈欲望的想法。他们说，他们只需要将疯狂的耻辱从同性恋中去除，以便他们能获得教书或从事精神病学工作的机会——基本上，是为了让他们最终能实现平权。
Now at the time, these protests didn't make much of an impression on the doctors at the APA. They saw themselves as scientists. And scientifically, there was near universal agreement that homosexuals were at least one donut short of a dozen.
当时，这些抗议对APA的医生们并没有留下深刻印象。他们认为自己是科学家。而从科学角度看，几乎普遍一致的看法是，同性恋者的心智不健全。
I spoke to 10 different psychiatrists who were members of the APA during the time of the redefinition, and I began each of my interviews with the same question-- what percentage of the APA believed that homosexuality was pathology in 1970 when this story begins?
我采访了10位在重新定义期间担任APA成员的精神科医生，我用同样的问题开始了我的每一次采访——在这个故事开始的1970年，有多少比例的APA成员认为同性恋是病态的？
Oh, well over 90%.
哦，远不止90%。
In 1970?
1970年？
Oh, I think so. Sure.
哦，我想是的。肯定。
95. 98. 99, even the ones of us who were gay.
95%。98%。99%，甚至连我们这些同性恋者也这么想。
This is John Fryer. John lives in Pennsylvania now in an aging Philadelphia mansion with two enormous dogs and rooms filled with elaborately scrolled furniture. This house is a very great distance, both psychologically and physically, from the Kentucky farm where John grew up.
这就是约翰·弗莱尔（John Fryer）。约翰现在住在宾夕法尼亚州，在一座古老的费城宅邸里，养了两条巨大的狗，房间里摆满了精心雕刻的家具。这座房子在心理上和物理上都与约翰长大的肯塔基农场有着非常遥远的距离。
John graduated from his Kentucky high school when he was only 15 years old. And by 19, he'd been accepted to Vanderbilt University Medical School. He was one of the youngest students to be trained in psychiatry in the school's history. He was also a homosexual.
约翰在15岁时就从肯塔基州的高中毕业了。到19岁时，他已被范德比尔特大学医学院录取。他是该校历史上接受精神病学培训最年轻的学生之一。他也是一名同性恋者。
Now, technically, it was forbidden for homosexuals to practice psychiatry, and John knew that. He had, after all, read the literature. He'd seen the research. And he had certainly sat through the lectures.
在当时，同性恋者从事精神病学工作在技术上是被禁止的，约翰也知道这一点。毕竟，他阅读过相关文献。他看过研究。他肯定也听过讲座。
So from the very beginning, I learned that it was pathology. And it was very difficult to get over that.
所以我从一开始就知道那是病态。要克服这种想法非常困难。
Difficult to get over, even years later, after he became a practicing psychiatrist. Difficult to get over, even after he joined the APA and met a number of other gay psychiatrists. So many, in fact, that informally they began to meet each year during APA conventions-- a loose underground group which they jokingly titled the GAYPA.
即使在多年后他成为一名执业精神科医生，也很难克服。即使在他加入APA并认识了其他许多同性恋精神科医生之后，也很难克服。事实上，他们人数多到在APA大会期间私下开始聚会——一个松散的地下组织，他们戏称为“GAYPA”。
These were men who, like John, had made it through medical school without detection and continued to hide their sexual preference, except to one another. These were men who, despite their association with the GAYPA, never thought to question, even among themselves, traditional psychiatric ideas about homosexuality.
这些人像约翰一样，在没有被察觉的情况下完成了医学院学业，并继续隐瞒他们的性取向，除了对彼此。尽管他们与“GAYPA”有关联，这些人却从未想过要质疑传统的精神病学关于同性恋的观点，即使是在他们自己中间。
No way.
绝不可能。
No way?
绝不可能？
Didn't come up, to my knowledge, because of our own internalized homophobia. Most of us probably agreed that it was OK to be a disease.
据我所知，从未提出过，因为我们自身内在的同性恋恐惧症。我们大多数人可能都认为“有病”是可以接受的。
The idea that homosexuality was a form of insanity began in the 19th century. And at least at the time, its designation as a mental illness was actually seen by homosexuals as a step forward.
同性恋是一种疯狂形式的观念始于19世纪。至少在当时，它被定性为精神疾病，实际上被同性恋者视为一种进步。
For the previous 2000 or so years, the Christian world saw being gay as a crime against the will of God. The book of Leviticus declares, "If a man lies with another man, as he would a woman, both have committed an abomination. They shall be put to death. Their blood shall be upon them."
在之前的两千年左右时间里，基督教世界将同性恋视为违背上帝旨意的罪行。《利未记》宣布：“人若与男人苟合，像与女人苟合，他们二人行了可憎的事，总要把他们治死，罪要归到他们身上。”
Then along came the head doctors and suddenly it wasn't the homosexual's fault. He was just another victim of faulty wiring, or possibly an overbearing mother. The shrinks weren't sure exactly what the problem was, but there was research-- a whole bunch of research-- from Freud on down.
后来，精神病医生出现了，突然之间，这不再是同性恋者的错。他只是线路故障的又一个受害者，或者可能是母亲过于强势的结果。精神病医生并不确定问题到底是什么，但确实有研究——一大堆研究——从弗洛伊德开始往下。
But by the late '60s when the status of homosexuals became an issue of public debate, the field was really dominated by two New York psychoanalysts. The first was a man named Charles Socarides. I'll talk about him later. The second was Dr. Irving Bieber, an analyst in New York who, at least originally, had no interest in the problem of homosexuality. Only became interested after he went to work as a psychiatrist in the Second World War. Irving Bieber is now deceased, but his wife, Dr. Toby Bieber, agreed to talk to me.
但到了60年代末，当同性恋者的地位成为公众辩论的话题时，该领域实际上被两位纽约的精神分析学家所主导。第一位是名叫查尔斯·索卡里德斯（Charles Socarides）的人。我稍后会谈到他。第二位是欧文·比伯（Irving Bieber）医生，他是纽约的一位分析师，至少最初，对比伯关于同性恋的问题没有兴趣。他在第二次世界大战中担任精神科医生后才对此产生兴趣。欧文·比伯现在已经去世了，但他的妻子托比·比伯（Dr. Toby Bieber）医生同意接受我的采访。
They would arrest homosexuals in the army. This was in India and in Egypt where he was in the CBI theater. They would arrest them and discharge them dishonorably. And the others would be hospitalized, something like that. So he got interested in the problem because he would be the psychiatrist who would examine these people.
在军队里，他们会逮捕同性恋者。这发生在他服役的印度和埃及的CBI战区。他们会逮捕他们并处以不光荣退伍。其他人会被送进医院之类。所以他对比伯的问题产生了兴趣，因为他会是检查这些人的精神科医生。
Toby Bieber says that during the war her husband defended homosexuals-- protested whenever a gay soldier was arrested or discharged, arguing he deserved treatment, not dishonor.
托比·比伯说，战争期间，她的丈夫为同性恋者辩护——每当有同性恋士兵被逮捕或退伍时，他都会抗议，认为他们应该得到治疗，而不是羞辱。
He got into trouble-- actually, a bit-- in the army. My husband went in as a captain, and he came out after four years-- he was in the Army for four years-- he came out as a captain. And he wasn't promoted, largely because of his defense of homosexuals in the army.
他在军队里确实遇到了一些麻烦。我丈夫参军时是上尉，四年后他退伍时——他在军队待了四年——他退伍时还是上尉。他没有得到晋升，很大程度上是因为他在军队里为同性恋者辩护。
So he saw himself as somebody who was helping homosexuals.
所以他把自己视为一个正在帮助同性恋者的人。
No question about it.
毫无疑问。
After the war, Dr. Bieber returned to the States and began research into the homosexual question in earnest. He assembled a crew of psychiatrists and undertook the single largest survey of homosexual behavior ever attempted. The project involved 77 doctors who contributed information on over 100 gay men and concluded that the cause of homosexuality was a combination of what they termed close-binding mothers, which is overprotective women who made their children weak and feminine, and detached, rejecting fathers.
战后，比伯医生回到美国，开始认真研究同性恋问题。他召集了一组精神科医生，进行了有史以来规模最大的同性恋行为调查。该项目涉及77名医生，他们贡献了超过100名男同性恋者的信息，并得出结论称，同性恋的原因是他们所称的“紧密联结的母亲”——即过度保护的女性让孩子变得软弱和女性化，以及疏离、排斥的父亲的结合。
The work was published in 1962 and immediately attracted the attention of the psychiatric world. It received the Hofheimer Award for original work. It also attracted the attention of another very different group of people-- homosexual activists.
这项工作发表于1962年，立即吸引了精神病学界的关注。它获得了霍夫海默原创工作奖。它也吸引了另一群非常不同的人——同性恋活动家。
A handful of homosexual organizations had begun in the early '50s and had grown slowly, both learning from and, in some ways, shadowing the progress of the civil rights and feminist movements. From its earliest days, one of the main goals of the gay groups, alongside civil rights, which was really number one, was removal from the DSM. So naturally, Bieber's study, which billed itself as definitive proof that homosexuality was a pathology, kind of rubbed them the wrong way.
少数同性恋组织在50年代初就开始出现并缓慢增长，他们既从民权运动和女权运动中学习，在某种程度上也在跟随它们的进展。从最早的日子起，同性恋团体的主要目标之一，除了民权（这是重中之重），就是从DSM中删除（关于同性恋的定性）。因此，自然而然地，比伯的研究——自诩为同性恋是病理的决定性证据——让他们感到非常不爽。
In 1970, the American Psychiatric Association made the mistake of holding its annual convention in San Francisco, which then, as now, had a large gay community. And the gay activists decided to protest. Irving Bieber was their very first target.
1970年，美国精神病学协会犯了一个错误，在旧金山举行了年会。当时和现在一样，旧金山有着庞大的同性恋群体。于是，同性恋活动家决定抗议。欧文·比伯是他们的首要目标。
The Washington Post, May 14th, 1970-- The gay liberation and the women allies out-shrinked the head shrinkers today and took over an American Psychiatric Association session on sex. Before the morning was over, the 500 psychiatrists who gathered to hear scientific studies on sexual problems demonstrated that they're just as prone to anti-social behavior as anyone else. "This lack of discipline is disgusting," said Dr. Leo Alexander, a psychiatrist at the meeting. Then he diagnosed the problem of one of the lesbian protesters. "She's a paranoid fool," the doctor said, "and a stupid bitch."
《华盛顿邮报》1970年5月14日报道——今天，同性恋解放运动和女性盟友压倒了那些精神病医生，接管了美国精神病学协会的一场关于性的会议。在上午结束之前，聚集在这里听取性问题科学研究的500名精神科医生表现出，他们和任何人一样容易产生反社会行为。“这种缺乏纪律的行为令人作呕，”会议上的精神科医生利奥·亚历山大（Leo Alexander）说道。然后，他诊断了其中一位女性抗议者的问题。“她是个偏执的傻瓜，”医生说，“也是个愚蠢的婊子。”
As I recall, there were evidently closeted gay and lesbian people who were inside the APA who kind of wanted something to happen. And I think they just passed along information to us. And somebody got us press passes, I guess, so that we could get through the front door.
据我回忆，当时APA内部显然有一些隐藏的同性恋男女，他们有点希望发生些什么。我想他们只是把信息传给了我们。我想有人给我们弄到了记者证，所以我们才能穿过前门。
This is Gary Allender, one of the gay activists who infiltrated the APA convention. He says that while one group of activists stormed a session on behavioral therapy, another combed the halls, looking for Bieber. They found him at a panel on transsexuals and homosexuality. Bieber, who was sitting in the front of the room, had just settled in for a nice long chat about close-binding mothers when, according to his wife, Toby, there was a loud noise from outside the auditorium.
这是加里·阿伦德尔（Gary Allender），渗透进APA大会的同性恋活动家之一。他说，当一群活动家冲进一场关于行为疗法的会议时，另一群人在大厅里搜寻比伯。他们在关于变性人和同性恋的小组讨论会上找到了他。坐在房间前排的比伯刚坐下来，准备就“紧密联结的母亲”进行一场愉快而漫长的谈话，根据他妻子托比的说法，礼堂外传来了巨大的噪音。
And a group came storming in, dressed rather fantastically with feathers in their hats, as though they were going to attend some costume ball, making noise and broke up the meeting. They broke it up.
一群人冲了进来，装扮得相当奇特，帽子上插着羽毛，就好像他们要去参加什么化装舞会一样，制造噪音并扰乱了会议。他们扰乱了会议。
We were not polite. We were not quiet. We were not asking for favors. We were just trying to delegitimize their authority. And we felt that they were oppressing us. And here was finally a chance to talk back to them.
我们并不礼貌。我们并不安静。我们没有寻求恩惠。我们只是试图取消他们的权威。我们觉得他们在压迫我们。这是终于有机会回敬他们的一次机会。
The protesters yelled at the psychiatrists. They called them sadists. They called them oppressors. But the protesters had an entirely different word for Irving Bieber, a word which, in the accounts that circulated after the event, got a disproportionate amount of attention. To the protesters, Dr. Bieber was not just your run of the mill sadist oppressor. No, sir. Irving Bieber was a mother [BLEEP].
抗议者向精神科医生大喊大叫。他们称他们为虐待狂。他们称他们为压迫者。但抗议者对欧文·比伯有一个完全不同的词，这个词在事件后流传的报道中引起了不成比例的关注。对于抗议者来说，比伯医生不仅仅是你司空见惯的虐待狂压迫者。不，先生。欧文·比伯是个“母亲（被哔——）者”。
This is not how you conduct a discourse, if you want to disagree with the people. Certainly, Darwin wasn't-- not that I'm comparing my husband to Darwin. But his work wasn't accepted either, but nobody called him a mother [BLEEP].
如果你想与人持不同意见，这不是进行对话的方式。当然，达尔文当时也没有——并不是说我在拿我丈夫和达尔文相比。但他的工作也没被接受，但没有人叫他“母亲（被哔——）者”。
By all accounts, this episode greatly disturbed and hurt Irving Bieber. Like most psychiatrists at the APA, he saw himself as someone who was helping, someone who had devoted his life to helping.
根据所有人的说法，这一事件极大地困扰并伤害了欧文·比伯。像APA的大多数精神科医生一样，他认为自己是一个正在提供帮助的人，一个毕生致力于提供帮助的人。
All of us did. All of us felt the same way.
我们所有人都是。我们所有人都有同样的感觉。
Which was how?
是什么感觉？
It was dismal to be accused of something that you're innocent of.
被指控犯有你无辜的事情是非常沉闷的。
This is Charles Socarides. Like Bieber, Socarides was one of the most lauded psychoanalysts in the profession-- a man who claims to have treated over 75 homosexuals in analysis and consulted with literally 1,000 more.
这是查尔斯·索卡里德斯。和比伯一样，索卡里德斯是职业中最受赞誉的精神分析学家之一——一个声称在分析中治疗过超过75名同性恋者，并咨询过另外1000多人的人。
Invariably, the goal of therapy with Socarides was to cure homosexual desire, to transform the patient into a heterosexual through analysis. At the time, this was common practice. There were all kinds of methods, from traditional talking treatment, to hormonal enhancement, to aversion therapy where patients were attached to electric shock machines, given gay pornography, and zapped if they demonstrated any kind of arousal.
索卡里德斯治疗的目标总是治愈同性恋欲望，通过分析将病人转变为异性恋者。在当时，这是普遍的做法。有各种各样的方法，从传统的谈话治疗，到荷尔蒙增强，再到厌恶疗法，即病人被连接到电击机上，观看同性恋色情片，如果他们表现出任何唤起迹象，就会受到电击。
Needless to say, the gay activists considered this treatment, even this goal, barbaric and sadistic-- an accusation which simply didn't make sense to Socarides.
不用说，同性恋活动家认为这种治疗，甚至这种目标，是野蛮和虐待狂的——这个指控对索卡里德斯来说根本说不通。
We only treat people who come to us, seek our help, and beg for our help. And we treat them with dignity, and with tact, and with loyalty, the same way we'd treat any other patient. So in the first place, to say, you are harming the homosexual was untrue. They even brought up that there are more suicides of people in treatment. That's not true.
我们只治疗那些来找我们、寻求我们帮助并恳求我们帮助的人。我们以尊严、机智和忠诚来对待他们，就像我们对待任何其他病人一样。所以首先，说“你在伤害同性恋者”是不真实的。他们甚至提到治疗中有更多人自杀。那不是真的。
But it wasn't just Socarides and Bieber who were uncomfortable with the accusations and demands of the gay activists. Most of the closeted psychiatrists of the GAYPA, like John Fryer, the gay psychiatrist you heard from earlier, were also disturbed.
但不仅仅是索卡里德斯和比伯对同性恋活动家的指控和要求感到不安。大多数像约翰·弗莱尔（之前提到过的那位同性恋精神科医生）这样隐藏着的“GAYPA”成员，也感到不安。
I frankly, at the beginning, remember the sense that I was embarrassed by it and that I wished they'd shut up. None of us were there.
坦白说，最初我记得有一种我为此感到尴尬的感觉，我希望他们闭嘴。我们谁也没在那儿。
None of the GAYPA were?
“GAYPA”的人都没去？
No. And I would say that all of us avoided that whole thing.
没有。而且我想说，我们所有人都避免了整件事。
It's not that they wanted to be seen as sick, it's just that they knew their colleagues-- or, anyway, they thought they knew their colleagues-- and believed that the psychiatrists of the APA would never change the definition.
并不是他们想被看作是有病的，只是他们了解自己的同事——或者至少，他们认为他们了解自己的同事——并相信APA的精神科医生永远不会改变这个定义。
Most of us didn't think this would happen.
我们大多数人不认为这会发生。
Didn't think what would happen?
不认为什么会发生？
That the nomenclature would be changed.
术语表会改变。
Right.
没错。
And I thought that it was just a fool's errand.
我以为那只是一个徒劳的努力。
What John didn't fully appreciate was that there were forces at work, forces at work deep inside the APA.
约翰没有完全意识到的是，当时有力量在运作，APA内部深处有力量在运作。
They met at our house. And that's how I came to know them and to know what they were trying to achieve.
他们在我们家开会。这就是我了解他们以及了解他们试图达成什么目标的原因。
This is Adam Spiegel, better known to this reporter, at least, as Dad. Adam Spiegel / Dad grew up with John P. Spiegel / Grandpa in a boxy Victorian off Brattle Street in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
这是亚当·斯皮格尔（Adam Spiegel），也就是我的父亲。亚当·斯皮格尔/我父亲与约翰·P·斯皮格尔/我祖父一起，在马萨诸塞州剑桥布拉特尔街旁的一座方方正正的维多利亚式房子里长大。
By the early 70s, Dad had moved out of this house to his own house in Baltimore, Maryland. But he still came back regularly for holidays. And often during these visits, he would find gathered around the kitchen table of his childhood home a group of men that my Aunt Mamie dubbed the "Young Turks."
到了70年代初，父亲已经搬出了这所房子，搬到了马里兰州巴尔的摩自己的家里。但他仍然定期回来过节。在这些访问期间，他经常会在他童年家中的餐桌旁发现一群男人，我姑妈玛米把他们称为“青年土耳其党人”。
The Young Turks were all psychiatrists, all members of the APA, and all liberal-minded Easterners who had decided to reform the American Psychiatric Association from the inside. Specifically, they had decided to replace all the gray-haired conservatives who ran the organization with a new breed of psychiatrist, more sensitive to the social issues of the day, with liberal opinions on Kent State, Vietnam, feminism.
“青年土耳其党人”都是精神科医生，都是APA成员，也都是具有自由思想的东方人，他们决定从内部改革美国精神病学协会。具体来说，他们决定用一种新的精神科医生品种取代所有管理该组织的灰发保守派，这种新品种对当时的社会议题更敏感，对肯特州立大学枪击案、越南、女权主义都有自由主义观点。
They figured that once they got this new breed into office, they could fundamentally transform American psychiatry. And one of the things this group was keen to transform was American psychiatry's approach to homosexuality.
他们认为，一旦他们把这种新品种送入办公室，他们就能从根本上改变美国精神病学。而这个群体热衷于改变的事情之一，就是美国精神病学对待同性恋的态度。
And so they gathered around my grandfather's kitchen table, over the delicate graven flowers of my grandmother's china, they'd discuss offenses and defenses-- map strategy.
于是他们聚集在我祖父的餐桌旁，在我祖母骨瓷餐具精致的浮雕花朵之上，讨论进攻和防守——规划策略。
The meetings, I thought, were all in great, good spirits. They all sat around rollicking with laughter about what they were planning to do. And they were serious, but they were also able to take a look at themselves. And it was just a small kind of cohort group that seized the moment to put across a huge-- what? Something on the 18,000 American shrinks of the APA.
我认为这些会议的气氛都很好。他们都坐在那里，为他们计划做的事情大声欢笑。他们是认真的，但他们也能审视自己。这只是一个小型的同伙群体，抓住了机会去施加一个巨大的——什么呢？对APA的18,000名美国精神医生施加影响。
As active members in an APA subcommittee, called the Committee for Concerned Psychiatry, the Young Turks proposed candidates for office, politicked for internal change.
作为APA一个名为“关心精神病学委员会”的委员会的活跃成员，青年土耳其党人提名候选人，为内部变革搞政治活动。
Now, I should point out that the group that gathered around my grandfather's kitchen table, and really around kitchen tables all over the East Coast, was not by any stretch of the imagination a homosexual cabal. But several of the key players were gay-- people like Dr. Larry Hartmann, who was a founding member of the Committee for Concerned Psychiatry, and later, like my grandfather, became president of the APA.
现在，我应该指出，聚集在我祖父厨房餐桌旁，实际上是聚集在整个东海岸厨房餐桌旁的群体，绝不是同性恋阴谋集团。但几位关键人物是同性恋——比如拉里·哈特曼（Larry Hartmann）医生，他是“关心精神病学委员会”的创始成员，后来和我祖父一样，成为了APA的主席。
Of course, none of these men were out at the time. They weren't even members of the GAYPA. They were too buried-- buried even to friends and family. Adam Spiegel.
当然，当时这些人中没有一个是出柜的。他们甚至不是“GAYPA”的成员。他们掩盖得太深了——对朋友和家人也是如此。亚当·斯皮格尔。
It was not clear to me. In fact, when I learned that Larry was gay, I almost fell out of my chair because he was so not gay in his affect-- impossible to discern.
这对我来说并不清楚。事实上，当我得知拉里是同性恋时，我差点从椅子上掉下来，因为他在情感表现上一点也不像同性恋——根本无法察觉。
Although the gay activists who were protesting the APA from the outside didn't know it, it was this group of men, these Young Turks and their allies, who laid the groundwork for the change in the DSM.
虽然当时从外部抗议APA的同性恋活动家们不知道，但正是这群人，这些“青年土耳其党人”和他们的盟友，为DSM的改变奠定了基础。
Without moving liberal-minded psychiatrists into positions of power in the APA, without changing the organization's internal infrastructure, there would have been an immediate veto of any attempt to change those extremely troublesome 81 words.
如果不把具有自由思想的精神科医生送入APA的权力职位，不改变该组织的内部基础设施，那么任何想要改变那极具麻烦的81个词的企图都会立即被否决。
Coming up, the scientific evidence that homosexuals might not be sick and how a party in a Hawaiian bar can change everything. Alix Spiegel's story continues in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，是关于同性恋者可能没有病的科学证据，以及夏威夷酒吧里的派对如何改变一切。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔的故事在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续后一分钟继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, we're devoting our whole program to the story of how and why the American Psychiatric Association decided, in 1973, that homosexuality is not a disease.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们将整个节目献给美国精神病学协会如何在1973年决定同性恋不是一种疾病的故事，以及原因。
This weekend in December is the 45th anniversary of that milestone. Today's program was first broadcast back when way more of the people involved in this story were still alive, back in 2002. Alix Spiegel continues her story.
本周六是这一里程碑事件的45周年。今天的节目最早是在2002年播出的，当时参与这个故事的人中有更多还在世。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔继续她的故事。
While the Young Turks worked from the inside, the gay activists continued their assault from the outside. They showed up at the American Psychiatric Association convention again in 1971, broke into the auditorium through a stage door during the opening ceremony, and stormed the podium.
当“青年土耳其党人”在内部工作时，同性恋活动家继续从外部进行攻击。他们在1971年再次出现在美国精神病学协会大会上，在开幕式期间通过舞台侧门闯入礼堂，并冲上讲台。
But it wasn't until the next year, at the '72 convention, that the gay activists hit upon a piece of political theater so outlandish that it actually managed to shake the dinosaurs at the APA. The spectacle was organized by Barbara Gittings, a librarian turned lesbian activist, who decided that it was time for the psychiatrists to hear from one of their own-- to hear from someone like John Fryer.
但直到第二年，也就是72年的大会，同性恋活动家才想出了一个如此离奇的政治戏剧，以至于它真的成功地震动了APA里的那些恐龙。这个奇观是由芭芭拉·吉廷斯（Barbara Gittings）组织的，她曾是一名图书管理员，后来成为同性恋活动家，她决定是时候让精神科医生听听他们自己人的一位声音了——听听像约翰·弗莱尔这样的人。
I got a call from Barbara Gittings about November of '71. She said, John, I'm looking for a psychiatrist to come and testify, a gay psychiatrist, to testify what it is like to be a good psychiatrist.
我在71年11月左右接到了芭芭拉·吉廷斯的电话。她说，约翰，我正在寻找一位精神科医生来作证，一位同性恋精神科医生，去作证当一个好的精神科医生是什么感觉。
The call from Barbara Gittings came at a particularly awkward moment in the life of John Fryer. He had recently been dismissed from his position as a resident in psychiatry at the University of Pennsylvania because his boss suspected he was gay. He was fired from another hospital in Philadelphia for the same reason.
芭芭拉·吉廷斯的电话打来时，正是约翰·弗莱尔生命中一个特别尴尬的时刻。他最近因为老板怀疑他是同性恋而被解除了在宾夕法尼亚大学担任精神科住院医生的职位。因为同样的原因，他被费城的另一家医院解雇了。
John had applied for other positions and professorships at a variety of universities, but the rumors of his sexual preference followed him, and so he was turned away. More than anything, John wanted to teach. And he definitely didn't want to do anything that might jeopardize his ability to get a faculty position.
约翰曾向多所大学申请其他职位和教授职位，但关于他性取向的流言追随着他，所以他被拒之门外。约翰最想要的是教书。他绝对不想做任何可能危及他获得教职能力的事情。
My first reaction was, no way. But she planted in my mind the possibility that I could do something and that I could do something that would be helpful, without ruining my career.
我的第一反应是，绝不可能。但她在我的脑海中种下了这种可能性，即我可以做些有帮助的事情，而不会毁掉我的职业生涯。
John told Barbara to find someone else. But four months later, Barbara called back. She had tried, she said, to find another gay psychiatrist, but no one would take the chance.
约翰告诉芭芭拉去找别人。但四个月后，芭芭拉又打来电话。她说，她尝试寻找另一位同性恋精神科医生，但没人敢冒这个险。
And so, Barbara Gittings offered John Fryer a compromise. They-- she and John-- would create an alternate personality, a disguise so fantastical that John's own mother wouldn't know him if he sat in her lap. They would call this creation Dr. Anonymous. And as Dr. Anonymous, John would address the members of the APA at the '72 convention in Dallas.
于是，芭芭拉·吉廷斯向约翰·弗莱尔提出了一个妥协方案。他们——她和约翰——将创造一个另类的人格，一个如此离奇的伪装，以至于约翰的亲生母亲坐在他腿上都认不出他。他们会把这个创造物称为“匿名医生（Dr. Anonymous）”。作为“匿名医生”，约翰将在达拉斯的72年大会上向APA成员发表讲话。
He would be given a hotel room to change in and a microphone to disguise his voice. All his expenses would be paid for. John told Barbara he would do it, then he called a friend.
他会得到一个酒店房间用来更衣，还有一个麦克风来伪装他的声音。他所有的费用都将由对方支付。约翰告诉芭芭拉他会这么做，然后他给一个朋友打了电话。
My friend, who was in drama, and I talked about what would be the most effective disguise. And you may or may not know this, but if you wear clothes that are much too large for you, you look much smaller than you are. So we made arrangements to rent a large and very flamboyant tuxedo.
我的朋友是学戏剧的，我们讨论了什么样的伪装最有效。你可能知道也可能不知道，但如果你穿比你大得多的衣服，你看上去会比实际小得多。所以我们租了一件又大又华丽的燕尾服。
We then decided that the best way to do my head was an over the head rubber mask. It was a Nixon mask that we distorted, so that you couldn't even see it was Nixon.
然后我们决定，处理我头部的最好方法是戴一个橡胶头套。那是一个尼克松面具，我们把它扭曲了，让你甚至看不出那是尼克松。
And so, in May of 1972, standing on stage in front of an audience of his peers in a wig, a Nixon mask, and a multicolored tuxedo three times his size, John Fryer made his case against 81 words.
于是，在1972年5月，约翰·弗莱尔站在台上，在众多同行面前，戴着假发，戴着尼克松面具，穿着一件比他大三倍的多色燕尾服，提出了他反对那81个词的理由。
He explained to his fellow psychiatrists how these words had harmed him and others like him. As he did this, he glanced occasionally at a man sitting just a few feet away from him in the front row. It was the man who had fired John from his hospital position several years before.
他向他的精神科医生同僚解释了这些词如何伤害了他和像他这样的人。在他讲述时，他偶尔瞥了一眼坐在他前面几英尺处的一名男子。那正是几年前将约翰从医院职位上解雇的人。
I received a standing ovation. And I felt-- I felt very empowered at that moment.
我获得了起立鼓掌。在那一刻，我感到——我感到非常有力量。
It was around this time, fall of 1972, that the Young Turks saw the first fruits of their labor. One of their candidates for office, a man named Alfred Freedman, was elected president of the APA.
大约在1972年秋天，“青年土耳其党人”看到了他们努力的初步成果。他们的一位候选人，名叫阿尔弗雷德·弗里德曼（Alfred Freedman）的人，当选为APA主席。
My grandfather, John Spiegel, was installed on the board of trustees. And another man, Judd Marmor, one of my grandfather's best friends and an outspoken critic of the idea that homosexuality should be categorized as a disease, was selected as vice president. This turn of events was naturally distressing to the opponents of the change, Irving Bieber and his friend, Dr. Charles Socarides.
我的祖父约翰·斯皮格尔进入了董事会。另一位名叫贾德·马莫尔（Judd Marmor）的人——我祖父最好的朋友之一，也是“同性恋应被归类为疾病”这一观点的直言不讳的批评者——被选为副主席。这一转折自然让那些反对变革的人——欧文·比伯和他的朋友查尔斯·索卡里德斯医生感到苦恼。
I know. I talked to the outgoing president at the time. He shook his head. He said, I don't know what's going to happen now. They've got gays galore. They're running for office. One of them may be president.
我知道。我当时和即将离任的主席谈过。他摇了摇头。他说，我不知道现在会发生什么。他们有太多的同性恋了。他们正在竞选公职。其中一个可能成为主席。
Suddenly, Bieber and Socarides found themselves in a position that, just two years before, they could not have conjured in their most outlandish nightmares. They were becoming professional renegades. And the work that established their reputations was under fire. Again, Charles Socarides.
突然之间，比伯和索卡里德斯发现自己处于一种地位，两年前他们甚至无法在最荒诞的噩梦中想象到。他们变成了专业的叛逆者。而确立他们声誉的工作也受到了攻击。再次回到查尔斯·索卡里德斯。
Papers that we wanted to give at various places, it was suddenly said, well, we don't think that would be a good thing to do right now in the current environment and the atmosphere.
我们想要在各个地方提交的论文，突然有人说，好吧，我们认为在当前的环境和气氛下，现在这样做可能不是件好事。
It wasn't just professional rejection. Personally, Bieber and Socarides had become targets. Angry gay activists followed them around, protesting every paper. There were threatening phone calls late at night and obscene messages scratched into the paint of department bathroom stalls.
这不仅仅是职业上的拒绝。在个人层面上，比伯和索卡里德斯成了目标。愤怒的同性恋活动家追随着他们，抗议每一篇论文。深夜有威胁电话，部门厕所隔间漆上还有猥亵信息。
All kinds of things-- that you're killing the gay men, that you're persecuting us, you ought to be dead. I mean, things like that-- all kinds of death threats.
各种各样的事情——你们在杀害男同性恋者，你们在迫害我们，你们应该死。我是说，类似的事情——各种各样的死亡威胁。
I went to Kansas City one day, Topeka. And one of my friends said I have a gift for you. And so he gave me a package. It was a gun. He says, Charles-- he says, you're really going to have to defend yourself. Of course, I never used it, but you felt like carrying it around as people followed you to a meeting and raising terrible threat calls.
有一天我去了堪萨斯城的托皮卡。我的一位朋友说，我有一份礼物给你。于是他给了我一个包裹。那是一把枪。他说，查尔斯——他说，你真的必须保卫自己。当然，我从未使用过它，但当人们跟着你去开会并发出可怕的威胁电话时，你会想随身携带它。
Socarides never took the professional criticism of his work seriously. A true believer in the psychoanalytic method, Socarides felt his research was sound and that he was, as he told me, doing God's work.
索卡里德斯从不认真对待对他工作的职业批评。作为精神分析方法的坚定信徒，索卡里德斯觉得他的研究是扎实的，正如他告诉我的那样，他是在“做上帝的工作”。
My views were the most solid clinical and theoretical studies on homosexuality, describing its origin, its course, its therapy, its symptoms. Most of the guys had never seen a homosexual. They'd never dealt with his unconscious material, or his dream material, or his transference. They don't know what goes on in the mind of a homosexual. All they see is the homosexual, who appears quite normal. But underneath, they don't know the dynamics and the meaning of his inability to approach a woman-- the pathology behind it.
我的观点是关于同性恋最可靠的临床和理论研究，描述了它的起源、过程、治疗和症状。大多数人以前从未见过同性恋者。他们从未处理过他的无意识材料、梦的材料或移情。他们不知道同性恋者的头脑里发生了什么。他们所看到的只是看起来很正常的同性恋者。但在内心深处，他们不知道他无法接近女性的动力学和含义——以及背后的病理。
Now, we need to take a moment to talk about the science. As I've said, for most of its history, psychiatry took for granted the idea that homosexuality was a pathology-- a grave distortion of normal development which demanded some kind of explanation.
现在，我们需要花点时间谈谈科学。正如我所说，在其历史的大部分时间里，精神病学认为同性恋是一种病理——一种对正常发展的严重扭曲，需要某种解释。
The question that concerned the psychiatrists then was what exactly had gone wrong with these people? Was it the mother? Was it the father? Was it frustration in the Oedipal phase? Or simply an excessive preoccupation with one's own genitalia? A lot of very intelligent men with years of university education and walls full of calligraphy certificates spent countless hours trying to pin down exactly who or what was to blame, which was pretty much the state of affairs until Evelyn Hooker met Sam Fromm.
当时困扰精神科医生的问题是：这些人究竟出了什么问题？是母亲的原因？父亲的原因？是俄狄浦斯阶段的挫折？还是仅仅对自己的生殖器过度关注？许多受过多年大学教育、挂满书法证书墙的聪明人，花费了无数时间试图找出到底是谁或什么是罪魁祸首。这种情况一直持续到伊夫琳·胡克（Evelyn Hooker）遇见萨姆·弗洛姆（Sam Fromm）。
Evelyn was a psychologist at UCLA, and Sam was her student. He's also a homosexual. They started spending time together in the mid-40s. And Sam introduced everyone to his group of friends, most of whom, like Sam, are gay.
伊夫琳是加州大学洛杉矶分校的一名心理学家，萨姆是她的学生。他也是一名同性恋者。他们在40年代中期开始在一起相处。萨姆把大家介绍给了他的朋友群，其中大多数人像萨姆一样是同性恋。
Now, as I said, everyone in this particular group was homosexual, but curiously, none in the group was in therapy. They were all very well-adjusted young men who utterly failed to conform to the traditional psychiatric image of the tortured, disturbed homosexual. This naturally got Evelyn thinking.
正如我所说，这个特定群体中的每个人都是同性恋，但奇怪的是，群体中没有人接受治疗。他们都是非常适应良好的年轻人，完全不符合传统精神病学中那种被折磨、被干扰的同性恋者的形象。这自然让伊夫琳陷入了思考。
Now, prior to Evelyn Hooker, all of the research in homosexuality-- all of it-- was done on people who were already under serious psychiatric treatment. Let me repeat that. In the history of psychiatric research, no one had ever conducted a study on a homosexual population that wasn't either in therapy, or prison, a mental hospital, or the disciplinary barracks of the armed services.
在伊夫琳·胡克之前，所有关于同性恋的研究——所有的——都是在已经接受严肃精神病治疗的人身上进行的。让我重申一遍。在精神病学研究史上，从未有人对非治疗中、非监狱、非精神病院或非武装部队纪律营中的同性恋群体进行过研究。
Evelyn thought about this and decided that this kind of research was distorting psychiatry's conclusions about homosexual populations. To test her theory, Evelyn came up with an experiment. Through her former student, she located 30 homosexuals who had never sought therapy in their lives and matched those homosexuals with a group of heterosexuals of comparable age, IQ, and education.
伊夫琳思考了这一点，并认为这种研究扭曲了精神病学关于同性恋群体的结论。为了验证她的理论，伊夫琳想出了一个实验。通过她以前的学生，她找到了30名从未寻求过治疗的同性恋者，并将这些同性恋者与一组年龄、智商和受教育程度相当的异性恋者进行了匹配。
Evelyn then put both groups through a battery of psychological tests, including a Rorschach test-- the famous inkblot test. After disguising her subjects, Evelyn gave the results to three experienced psychiatrists and asked them to identify the homosexuals. She figured that if homosexuals were inherently pathological, the psychiatrists would be able to pick them out easily.
伊夫琳随后让两组人接受了一系列心理测试，包括罗夏墨迹测试——著名的墨迹测试。在隐瞒了受试者身份后，伊夫琳将结果交给三位经验丰富的精神科医生，并要求他们识别出哪些是同性恋者。她认为，如果同性恋者天生具有病理性，精神科医生应该很容易把他们挑出来。
But the judges were completely unable to distinguish the homos from the hets. Equally important was the fact that the judges categorized 2/3 of both the homosexuals and the heterosexuals as perfectly well-adjusted, normally functioning human beings.
但评委们完全无法区分同性恋者和异性恋者。同样重要的是，评委们将2/3的同性恋者和异性恋者都归类为完美适应、功能正常的正常人。
Hooker's study challenged the idea that homosexuality was a pathology in the first place. And in doing this, it not only called into question an entire generation of research on homosexuality, it also challenged psychiatry's basic concept of disease.
胡克的研究首先挑战了同性恋是一种病理的观念。这样做不仅质疑了整整一代关于同性恋的研究，也挑战了精神病学的基本疾病概念。
If you believed Hooker's data, then the only conclusion you could come to was that psychiatry was declaring certain behaviors were diseases not out of any sort of scientific proof, but based on their own prejudices. This was something that psychiatrists had been accused of before, most famously by a psychoanalyst named Thomas Szasz, who argued in the 1950s and '60s that certain dangerous psychiatric treatments, like electroshock therapy, were prescribed with no scientific basis and that psychiatrists were essentially in the business of enforcing social norms.
如果你相信胡克的数据，那么你只能得出结论：精神病学宣称某些行为是疾病，并非出于任何形式的科学证据，而是基于他们自己的偏见。这一点以前曾有精神科医生被指控过，最著名的是一位名叫托马斯·萨兹（Thomas Szasz）的精神分析学家，他在50年代和60年代主张，某些危险的精神科治疗（如电休克疗法）是在没有科学依据的情况下开出的，精神科医生本质上是在做强制社会规范的工作。
But Szasz didn't provide the gay activists any hard data to use in their fight with the psychiatrists. Aside from Hooker, the most useful scientific studies supporting their side was Alfred Kinsey's famous 1948 sex survey, which found that a whopping 37% of all men had had physical contact to the point of orgasm with other men, a finding which, besides shocking the hell out of 63% of the American public, seemed to suggest that homosexual acts were too common to be considered a disease.
但萨兹并没有提供任何硬数据供同性恋活动家在与精神科医生的斗争中使用。除了胡克之外，支持他们一方最有用的科学研究是阿尔弗雷德·金赛（Alfred Kinsey）著名的1948年性调查，该调查发现，高达37%的所有男性曾与男性有达到性高潮程度的身体接触。这一发现除了让63%的美国公众大吃一惊外，似乎也表明同性恋行为过于普遍，不能被视为一种疾病。
In spite of all this work, psychiatry continued to maintain that the homos were sick and steadfastly refused to re-evaluate the DSM. And then luck, or maybe fate, intervened, intervened in the form of a chance meeting between a gay activist on the outside and an open-minded insider. That open-minded insider? Dr. Robert L. Spitzer.
尽管做了所有这些工作，精神病学仍坚持认为同性恋者有病，并坚定地拒绝重新评估DSM。然后，幸运，或者可能是命运，进行了干预。这种干预以一个外部同性恋活动家和内部一个开明人士之间偶然相遇的形式出现。那个开明人士？罗伯特·L·斯皮策（Robert L. Spitzer）医生。
My view was no different, I think, from the standard view. I totally accepted it.
我的观点我认为和标准观点没什么不同。我完全接受它。
Totally accepted what?
完全接受什么？
The idea that homosexuality was an illness.
同性恋是一种疾病的观点。
In the fall of 1972, Robert Spitzer was only loosely aware of the controversy. He knew about the protests, he knew about Dr. Anonymous, of course, Socarides and Bieber, but he hadn't really taken a professional interest in the issue. At the time, Robert Spitzer was a relatively young, but very ambitious man, and most importantly, at least to this story, a junior member of the APA's Committee on Nomenclature.
1972年秋天，罗伯特·斯皮策对这场争议只有一点点了解。他当然知道抗议活动、知道“匿名医生”、知道索卡里德斯和比伯，但他并没有真正对这个问题产生职业兴趣。当时，罗伯特·斯皮策是一名相对年轻但非常有野心的人，最重要的是——至少对这个故事来说——他是APA术语委员会的一名低级别成员。
For those of you who didn't spend four years in medical school, the Committee on Nomenclature is the group which decides which mental disorders will appear in the DSM. In other words, these were the people who actually decided what was and what was not a mental illness-- the people with the most direct, unmediated control over those extremely troublesome 81 words.
对于那些没在医学院待过四年的人来说，“术语委员会”是决定哪些精神障碍会出现在DSM中的组织。换句话说，这些人是实际决定什么是、什么不是精神疾病的人——对那些极具麻烦的81个词拥有最直接、未中介控制权的人。
If Robert Spitzer chose to get involved, he would have been in a great position to help the activists. But like I said, he hadn't really taken an interest, not until one day in the fall of '72, when he showed up at a behavioral therapy conference in New York City. Now, it just so happened that this particular behavioral therapy conference had been infiltrated by a group called the Gay Activists Alliance. Among them was a man named Ronald Gold.
如果罗伯特·斯皮策选择参与，他本可以处于一个极好的位置来帮助活动家。但正如我所说，他并没有真正产生兴趣，直到72年秋天的一天，当他出现在纽约市的一个行为疗法会议上。现在，恰好这个特定的行为疗法会议被一个叫“同性恋活动家联盟”的组织渗透了。其中有一个人叫罗纳德·戈尔德（Ronald Gold）。
We went to this meeting, and we're all sitting there like everybody else. And at a particular time, the idea was for somebody to get up and say, sorry, we're taking you over. And he didn't show up. And so they all sort of looked at me and said, you've got to do it.
我们去参加这个会议，我们都像其他人一样坐在那里。在某个特定的时间，计划是让某个人站起来说，抱歉，我们接管了你们的会议。但他没出现。所以他们都看着我说，你必须去做。
At the time, Ronald Gold, like Robert Spitzer, was a minor figure in this battle. He had recently quit his job as a reporter for Variety to become media director of the Gay Activists Alliance, but he almost never made speeches. He was strictly a backstage kind of guy.
当时，罗纳德·戈尔德和罗伯特·斯皮策一样，在这场斗争中只是个小人物。他最近辞去了《综艺》杂志记者的工作，成为了“同性恋活动家联盟”的媒体总监，但他几乎从不演讲。他是一个严格的幕后人物。
But at this conference, when the usual speech maker didn't show, Ron got up and railed against the psychiatrist himself. Apparently made enough of a spectacle to tick off Robert Spitzer who, after the meeting, decided to tell Ron off. Ronald Gold.
但在这次会议上，当惯常的演讲者没出现时，罗恩站起来自己抨击了精神科医生。显然这制造了足够的奇观，让罗伯特·斯皮策感到不悦，会议结束后，他决定训斥罗恩。罗纳德·戈尔德。
When it was all over, this woman, who was a friend of mine, came by to say hi, and good job, or words to that effect. And she introduced me to this man, who happened to be with her, who was Dr. Robert Spitzer.
当这一切结束后，这个女人，是我的一位朋友，走过来打招呼，说干得好之类的话。她把我介绍给了这个和她在一起的男人，他就是罗伯特·斯皮策医生。
I complained to him, you know? You've broken up a meeting. You're not letting-- you know, it's one thing to talk, but it's another thing to break up a meeting. And we started to have a discussion. And at some point in that discussion, well, he learned that I was on this committee.
我向他抱怨，你知道吗？你扰乱了一场会议。你不让——你知道，谈话是一回事，但扰乱会议是另一回事。我们开始讨论。在讨论的某个时候，嗯，他得知我是这个委员会的成员。
And I said to him, do two things for us. Set up a meeting for us with the Nomenclature Committee, and set up some kind of a panel discussion at the next convention and allow us to participate.
于是我对他说，为我们做两件事。为我们安排一次与术语委员会的会议，并在下一次大会上安排某种小组讨论，让我们参与。
Ron asked formally for permission to speak to our committee.
罗恩正式申请了向我们委员会发言的许可。
He was interested. I think he was intrigued by the-- you'd have to talk to him exactly about what his feelings at the time were.
他感兴趣。我想他被那些——你必须确切地问他当时的感觉是什么。
I started off by feeling they're wrong, but they're interesting. And something I wanted to understand-- their viewpoint. That's how it started.
我一开始的感觉是他们错了，但他们很有趣。我想理解一些事情——他们的观点。这就是开始的方式。
Robert Spitzer arranged for an appearance in front of the Nomenclature Committee, as promised. Several months later, three gay activists presented their case to the Nomenclature doctors, who listened, and nodded, and, after their presentation was done and the room was cleared, had absolutely no idea what to do about it. Even Robert Spitzer wasn't sure where he stood on the issue, and so he came up with a plan.
罗伯特·斯皮策按照承诺安排了在术语委员会面前的露面。几个月后，三位同性恋活动家向术语委员会医生陈述了他们的理由，这些医生听着，点着头，在演示结束后，房间清空后，完全不知道该怎么办。甚至罗伯特·斯皮策也不确定自己在问题上的立场，所以他想出了一个计划。
Spitzer decided that the two sides, who had been shouting at one another for over two years, but incredibly, hadn't officially met face to face, should have an organized debate-- a final meeting between the two sides.
斯皮策决定，两方——已经互相喊叫了两年多，但不可思议的是，并没有正式面对面见过面——应该进行一场有组织的辩论——双方之间的最后一次会议。
And so, for the 1973 APA convention in Honolulu, Spitzer organized a forum where both sides could directly argue the merits of the case with each other. The old guard, Charles Socarides and Irving Bieber, publicly met the new school, Ronald Gold, Judd Marmor, and several other psychiatrists, in front of a room filled to capacity. Ronald Gold.
于是，在1973年檀香山APA大会上，斯皮策组织了一个论坛，双方可以直接互相争论案件的优点。老派人物查尔斯·索卡里德斯和欧文·比伯，在座无虚席的房间里，公开会见了新学派的罗纳德·戈尔德、贾德·马莫尔和其他几位精神科医生。罗纳德·戈尔德。
The title of my speech was "Stop It, You're Making Me Sick." And essentially, I said that the diagnosis of the illness of homosexuality is the greatest tool of oppression imaginable. And that they've got to take us out of the nomenclature and in order to prevent this from being the kind of sick that you get when people are repressing you.
我的演讲题目是“停止吧，你让我觉得恶心”。基本上，我说将同性恋定为疾病是你能想象到的最伟大的压迫工具。他们必须把我们从术语中剔除，以防止这成为那种当人们压迫你时你会感受到的那种“病”。
Gold says you're all rats, and you're all inhuman, and you're a disgrace to the profession.
戈尔德说你们都是老鼠，你们都是非人类，你们是职业的耻辱。
Socarides did his "they're betraying their mammalian heritage" number during the thing. They all just hooted. I mean, they just thought that was ridiculous.
索卡里德斯在过程中表演了他那套“他们在背叛他们的哺乳动物遗产”的数字。他们都嘘声一片。我是说，他们只是认为那很可笑。
I presented those findings at the national meeting in Hawaii. A lot of people booed. Some people clapped.
我在夏威夷的全国会议上发表了这些调查结果。很多人发出嘘声。有些人鼓掌。
One of the things he said in that panel was that there are no homosexuals in kibbutzes in Israel. And I had just come back from Israel, and had had a thing with somebody who was raised in a kibbutz. And I said so in their panel, and they all laughed hysterically. But it made him seem to be a perfect jackass, which, of course, he was.
他在那个小组里说的一件事是，以色列的基布兹里没有同性恋者。我刚从以色列回来，和一个在基布兹长大的人有过一段关系。我在他们的小组里说了出来，他们都歇斯底里地笑了。但这让他看起来像个完美的傻瓜，当然，他确实是。
But an equally important performance that day-- the performance which, at least according to Ronald Gold, finally convinced Robert Spitzer to sit down and redraft the 81 words in the Diagnostic and Statistics Manual-- was not the exchange between Ron and Charles Socarides in front of the psychiatrists of the APA.
但那天同样重要的表现——至少根据罗纳德·戈尔德的说法，最终说服罗伯特·斯皮策坐下来并起草《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中那81个词的表现——并不是罗恩和查尔斯·索卡里德斯在APA精神科医生面前的交流。
It didn't even take place in the upscale, beachfront hotel in which the conference was stationed. No. It took place in a bar later that night, in one of those campy Hawaiian lounges with bamboo furniture, grass skirted waitresses, and a three-page menu of exotically-colored drinks. This is where the GAYPA had decided to hold its annual party. Naturally, after his speech at the conference, Ron Gold got an invitation.
它甚至没有发生在会议所在的那个高档海滨酒店。不。它发生在当天晚上的一个酒吧里，在那些充满怀旧风情的夏威夷休息室之一，那里有竹制家具、草裙舞女招待和一份三页长的异国情调饮品菜单。这就是“GAYPA”决定举行年度派对的地方。自然，在会议演讲后，罗恩·戈尔德收到了邀请。
I got invited to this party, but I was told keep it all very quiet and don't say anything. And just come to this bar, and we'll all be there. So I decided to invite Spitzer to come to this because he had told me, essentially, that he didn't know any gay psychiatrists and wasn't quite sure there were any. And I said, you just come along.
我受邀参加这个派对，但我被告知要保持安静，什么都别说。只需来到这个酒吧，我们大家都会在那里。所以我决定邀请斯皮策参加，因为他基本上告诉我，他不认识任何同性恋精神科医生，也不确定是否有。我说，你就跟着来吧。
Ron warned Spitzer not to say anything. He was instructed not to speak, or stare, or indicate in any way that he was anything other than a closeted gay man.
罗恩警告斯皮策不要说话。他被指示不要发言、凝视，或以任何方式表明除了是一个隐藏的同性恋者之外的任何身份。
But once he got there and saw that the head of the Transactional Analysis Association and the guy who handed out all the training money in the United States, and the heads of various prestigious psychiatry departments at various universities were all there, he couldn't believe it. And he started asking all these absolutely dim-witted questions.
但一旦他到了那里，看到“交易分析协会”的主管、分发美国所有培训资金的人，以及各大学著名精神病学系的主任都在那里，他简直不敢相信。他开始问所有这些绝对愚蠢的问题。
Like what?
比如什么？
Oh, I can't even remember, but questions that no gay person would ask.
哦，我甚至记不清了，但那是同性恋者不会问的问题。
At the time, the members of the GAYPA were still completely hidden. They hadn't been active in the struggle to change the DSM. They were too fearful of losing their jobs to identify themselves publicly. So when Robert Spitzer, an obviously straight man in a position of power at the APA, appeared at the bar, the men of the GAYPA were completely unnerved.
当时，“GAYPA”的成员仍然完全隐蔽。他们没有积极参与改变DSM的斗争。他们太害怕失去工作，不敢公开身份。所以当罗伯特·斯皮策——一个明显的异性恋者，处于APA权力的位置——出现在酒吧时，“GAYPA”的男人们完全慌了。
So the Grand Dragon of the GAYPA, whoever he was, I can't remember now-- came up to me and said, get rid of him. Get him out of here. You got to get rid of him. And I said, I'm doing nothing of the kind. He's here to help us, and you are not doing anything.
所以，“GAYPA”的大龙（Grand Dragon），无论他是谁，我现在记不起来了——走过来对我说，让他滚。让他滚出去。你必须让他滚。我说，我才不会做这种事。他来这里是为了帮助我们，而你什么都没做。
And that's when it happened. There, in front of Robert Spitzer and the Grand Dragon of the GAYPA, there in the midst of neon-colored drinks and grass-skirted waitresses, a young man in full Army uniform walked into the bar. He looked at Robert Spitzer. He looked at Ronald Gold. He looked at the Grand Dragon of the GAYPA. And then the young man in uniform burst into tears. He threw himself into Ron's arms and remained there, sobbing.
就在那时，事情发生了。在那里，在罗伯特·斯皮策和“GAYPA”的大龙面前，在那里，在霓虹灯颜色的饮料和草裙女招待中间，一个穿着全套军装的年轻人走进酒吧。他看着罗伯特·斯皮策。他看着罗纳德·戈尔德。他看着“GAYPA”的大龙。然后那个穿军装的年轻人放声大哭。他扑进罗恩的怀里，留在那里抽泣。
Well, I had no idea who he was. It turned out he was a psychiatrist, an Army psychiatrist based in Hawaii, who was so moved by my speech, he told me, that he decided that he had to go to a gay bar for the first time in his life. And somehow or other, he got directed to this particular bar and saw me and all these gay psychiatrists. And it was too much for him. He just cracked up.
嗯，我不知道他是谁。原来他是一位精神科医生，驻扎在夏威夷的军队精神科医生，他说他被我的演讲深深打动了，他决定他一生中第一次必须去一个同性恋酒吧。不知何故，他被指引到了这个特定的酒吧，看到了我和所有这些同性恋精神科医生。这对他说来太多了。他崩溃了。
And it was a very moving event. I mean, this man was awash in tears. And I believe that that was what decided Spitzer right then and there, let's go. And of course, it was right after that that he said, let's go write the resolution. And so we went back to Spitzer's hotel room and wrote the resolution.
那是一个非常动人的事件。我的意思是，这个人泪流满面。我相信那正是决定斯皮策就在那时、那里，行动起来的原因。当然，就在那之后他说，我们去写决议吧。于是我们回到斯皮策的酒店房间写了决议。
Right then? That night?
就在那时？那天晚上？
Right, that night.
没错，那天晚上。
Robert Spitzer's resolution didn't call for a flat-out elimination of homosexuality from the APA nomenclature. He didn't think that the psychiatrists of the APA would approve an outright deletion. Instead, it argued that in order for a behavior to be categorized as pathological, the behavior must cause, quote, "subjective distress." In other words, if you were gay and it didn't bother you, you weren't sick.
罗伯特·斯皮策的决议并没有呼吁彻底从APA术语中消除同性恋。他不认为APA的精神科医生会批准彻底删除。相反，它主张为了让某种行为被归类为病态，该行为必须导致——引用——“主观痛苦”。换句话说，如果你是同性恋且它不困扰你，你就不是有病。
For those homosexuals who were troubled by their orientation, Spitzer created a new category-- ego dystonic homosexuality. And it was the 237 words which followed this heading, which were eventually submitted to the reference committee, which was then headed by the president-elect of the APA-- my grandfather, Dr. John P Spiegel.
对于那些对自己的取向感到困扰的同性恋者，斯皮策创建了一个新类别——“自我不和谐同性恋”。正是这个标题后面的237个词，最终被提交给了参考委员会，该委员会当时由APA候任主席——我的祖父约翰·P·斯皮格尔医生领导。
Once the reference committee endorsed the change, it was sent to the board of trustees and the president of the APA, Dr. Alfred Freedman, one of the newly elected APA officials whose candidacy for office had been contrived and supported by the Committee for Concerned Psychiatry and the Young Turks, who sat around my grandfather's kitchen table.
参考委员会批准该变化后，它被送交董事会和APA主席阿尔弗雷德·弗里德曼医生，他是新当选的APA官员之一，他的参选是由当时聚集在我祖父厨房餐桌旁的“关心精神病学委员会”和“青年土耳其党人”策划和支持的。
On December 15, 1973, this president and this board called a press conference where they announced to the world that they had approved the deletion of homosexuality from the American Psychiatric Association's Diagnostic and Statistics Manual. Charles Socarides, naturally, was appalled.
1973年12月15日，这位主席和董事会召开了新闻发布会，向世界宣布他们批准了从美国精神病学协会的《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中删除同性恋。查尔斯·索卡里德斯自然感到震惊。
I said, holy [BLEEP]. They're changing the rules. If there's anything you couldn't change in this world would be the relationship between a male and a female. They go together. They go together through all of evolution, right up the animal kingdom, right to man. And now they're saying it's just as natural to mate with the same sex as it is with the opposite sex. What will psychiatry think? What will medicine think? What will pediatric think? They think we've gone insane.
我说，天哪。他们正在改变规则。如果说这世界上有什么是你不能改变的，那就是男性和女性之间的关系。它们在一起。它们通过整个进化过程在一起，一直到动物界，一直到人类。而现在他们说与同性交配和与异性交配一样自然。精神病学会怎么想？医学界会怎么想？儿科会怎么想？他们会以为我们疯了。
The headline in our newsletter at the National Gay Task Force was, "The Earth is round." And that's what it was to us. They finally got around to having a grain of sanity.
我们在全国同性恋任务组通讯的标题是，“地球是圆的”。这就是我们所感受到的。他们终于有了一丝理智。
So that's the story of how 81 words became 237 words. That's the story of a definition. Today, there's no entry in the DSM on homosexuality, no entry at all. In 1987, the 237 words that Robert Spitzer wrote about ego dystonic homosexuality were quietly removed.
这就是81个词如何变成237个词的故事。这就是定义的故事。今天，DSM里没有关于同性恋的条目，根本没有条目。1987年，罗伯特·斯皮策写的关于“自我不和谐同性恋”的237个词被悄悄删除了。
Meanwhile, the APA turned itself upside down. In 1970, 90% of the American Psychiatric Association believed that homosexuality was a pathology. Today, 90% believe that it's a normal variant of sexual behavior, no more pathological than something like left-handedness.
与此同时，APA翻天覆地。1970年，90%的美国精神病学协会成员认为同性恋是一种病理。今天，90%的人认为它是性行为的一种正常变体，不再比左撇子这种东西更具病理性。
In fact, it's now considered unethical to treat homosexuality. And any psychiatrist who attempts to change the sexual orientation of his patient can face professional censure. If a gay person finds his sexual preference disturbing, if he's interested in becoming heterosexual-- and there are many people who fit this description-- the APA guidelines suggest that the therapist counsel his patient that change is impossible.
事实上，现在治疗同性恋被认为是不道德的。任何试图改变其病人性取向的精神科医生都可能面临职业谴责。如果一个同性恋者发现自己的性偏好令人困扰，如果他有兴趣成为异性恋者——确实有许多人符合这种描述——APA的指导方针建议治疗师劝告病人，改变是不可能的。
My family always told me that my grandfather single-handedly changed the DSM. But what's striking is all the different forces that had to be in place in order to make this happen. It took both Evelyn Hooker and Dr. Anonymous, John P. Spiegel and Ronald Gold-- people on the outside, people on the inside, and people at every point in between. The change happened partly through scientific debate and partly simply because psychiatrists got to know gay men.
我的家人总是告诉我，我的祖父单枪匹马改变了DSM。但令人震惊的是，为了实现这一目标，所有必须到位的力量。这需要伊夫琳·胡克和“匿名医生”、约翰·P·斯皮格尔和罗纳德·戈尔德——外部的人、内部的人，以及中间每一点的人。这一变化部分通过科学辩论发生，部分仅仅是因为精神科医生开始了解同性恋者。
There are a couple of interesting postscripts to this story. Dr. Irving Bieber died in 1991, and the New York Times published an obituary which focused on his work and homosexuality in a way that his wife, Toby, found hostile and insulting. Most of the quotes were from people who never agreed with him.
这个故事还有几个有趣的后记。欧文·比伯医生于1991年去世，《纽约时报》发表了一篇讣告，其内容重点关注了他对比伯和同性恋的研究，其方式让他的妻子托比感到充满敌意和侮辱。大部分引用来自那些从未同意他观点的人。
Worse, the newspaper mistakenly printed a picture of Robert Spitzer, Dr. Bieber's longtime opponent, in Dr. Bieber's place. This misprint so infuriated his wife, Toby, that she canceled her subscription to the New York Times and never bought the newspaper again. When she wants to find out what's going on in the world, she says she watches television.
更糟糕的是，报纸错误地印刷了比伯医生的长期对手罗伯特·斯皮策的照片来代替比伯医生。这个印刷错误让他的妻子托比怒不可遏，她取消了《纽约时报》的订阅，再也没买过那份报纸。她说当她想了解世界上发生了什么时，她会看电视。
And then there's Charles Socarides. Dr. Socarides continues to teach and practice psychiatry, but his views on homosexuality have damaged his position in his profession. He's been violently criticized by his peers. And his book on homosexuality, called A Freedom Too Far, was refused by over 40 publishers. In the end, he had to print the book himself. But Socarides remains convinced that he has chosen the right path and claims that, far from destroying his career, his views on homosexuality have actually helped his practice.
还有查尔斯·索卡里德斯。索卡里德斯医生继续教书和从事精神病学工作，但他对同性恋的观点损害了他在专业领域的位置。他受到了同行的猛烈批评。他关于同性恋的书，名为《走得太远的自由（A Freedom Too Far）》，被40多家出版社拒绝。最终，他不得不自己出资印刷了这本书。但索卡里德斯仍然坚信他选择了正确的道路，并声称，远非毁掉他的职业生涯，他对同性恋的观点实际上帮助了他的业务。
Oh, it's made it boom.
哦，它让业务蓬勃发展。
It made it boom?
蓬勃发展？
Boom, sure. Sure. I'm known both as the devil of the radical gay movement, and I'm also known as the savior of many homosexual's lives.
蓬勃发展，当然。当然。我既被称为激进同性恋运动的魔鬼，也被称为许多同性恋生命的救世主。
Last week, I saw somebody with his son of 16 who said they've taken the boy to six psychiatrists in New Jersey, and everyone of them said, get out of here, or told him that he can't be helped. And that's happened over and over again.
上周，我见到一个人和他16岁的儿子，他说他们带那个男孩去了新泽西州的六个精神科医生那里，每个人都说，“滚出去”，或者告诉他没救了。这种情况发生过一次又一次。
I've heard a lot of terrible words against me, but my patients would tell you differently-- any one of them.
我听过很多针对我的可怕言论，但我的病人会告诉你不同的结果——他们中的任何一个。
One of the homosexuals who does not speak against Socarides is his eldest son, Richard Socarides, a lawyer who served as an advisor to the Clinton administration on lesbian and gay issues, and who helped to organize, among other things, a White House Conference on HIV and AIDS.
其中一位不反驳索卡里德斯的同性恋者是他的长子理查德·索卡里德斯（Richard Socarides），他是一位律师，曾担任克林顿政府关于同性恋问题的顾问，除其他事项外，还帮助组织了一场白宫关于艾滋病毒和艾滋病的会议。
Dr. Charles Socarides has told reporters that he wonders if he failed his son, Richard. That's the word he used, "failed." Dr. Socarides believes his own theories, and therefore believes that he is in some way responsible for his son's sexual orientation. A few years ago, his son, Richard, told the press, quote, "Our relationship is quite strained, but is a relationship, nonetheless."
查尔斯·索卡里德斯医生告诉记者，他想知道自己是否在儿子理查德身上失败了。那是他用的词，“失败”。索卡里德斯医生相信他自己的理论，因此相信他在某种程度上应对他儿子的性取向负责。几年前，他的儿子理查德告诉媒体，引用，“我们的关系相当紧张，但尽管如此，这依然是一种关系。”
Finally, there's my grandfather, Dr. John P. Siegel, whose postscript was written that day in the Bahamas in 1981 when he stepped out of his beachfront bungalow into the Caribbean sun, his new lover, David, on his arm.
最后，还有我的祖父约翰·P·斯皮格尔医生，他的后记是在1981年巴哈马群岛的那一天写的，当时他挽着他的新爱人大卫，走出了海滨平房，走进了加勒比海的阳光下。
Thank you very much, Grandpa. That was very interesting. I hope it's as interesting to listen to as it was to conduct the interview with you. End of interview. Bye-bye.
非常感谢，爷爷。那非常有趣。我希望听起来和采访你一样有趣。采访结束。再见。
Alix Siegel, who put that story together, these days is the co-host of the NPR show, Invisabilia, which is about the things that shape our ideas, and beliefs, and assumptions, very much along the lines of the story you just heard. It's available wherever you get your podcasts. And I know we say that all the time. If you don't actually have a place that you get podcasts, just type Invisabilia into Google search, and you will find it.
把那个故事拼凑起来的阿利克斯·斯皮格尔，这些天是NPR节目《不可见（Invisabilia）》的联合主持人，该节目讲述了塑造我们想法、信念和假设的事物，这与你们刚刚听到的故事非常吻合。它在你们获取播客的任何地方都可以听到。我知道我们总是这么说。如果你确实没有获取播客的地方，只需在谷歌搜索中输入“Invisabilia”，你就会找到它。
As I said earlier, we first aired today's program in 2002. In the years since then, so many people in the story have died-- Charles Socarides, John Fryer, Toby Bieber, who's Irving Bieber's wife, Gary Allender, who was one of the gay activists who infiltrated the APA convention, and Robert Spitzer and Ronald Gold, the unlikely pair who drafted the resolution after that fateful night in the Hawaiian tiki bar.
正如我之前所说，我们第一次播出今天的节目是在2002年。从那以后的几年里，故事中的许多人都去世了——查尔斯·索卡里德斯、约翰·弗莱尔、欧文·比伯的妻子托比·比伯、渗透APA大会的同性恋活动家之一加里·阿伦德尔，以及在那次夏威夷提基酒吧命运之夜后起草决议的、那一对不可思议的搭档罗伯特·斯皮策和罗纳德·戈尔德。
Special thanks to [INAUDIBLE] Martin Duberman, whose memoir Cures details what it was like to be a gay man undergoing therapy for homosexuality for a decade. Coincidentally, Radiolab just did a spectacularly good series of shows on this same period of history where psychiatry was rethinking homosexuality. I cannot recommend this enough. They've just been killing it lately. It's a few episodes that they call "Un-erased." Again, that's Radiolab, wherever you get your-- oh I'm not even going to say all that again.
特别感谢马丁·杜伯曼（Martin Duberman），他的回忆录《治愈（Cures）》详细描述了作为一名男同性恋者在十年间接受同性恋治疗是什么感觉。巧合的是，Radiolab刚刚制作了一系列非常出色的节目，讲述的是精神病学重新思考同性恋的同一历史时期。我怎么推荐都不为过。他们最近的表现真是太棒了。这几集他们称之为“未被抹去（Un-erased）”。再说一次，那是Radiolab，无论你在哪里获取你的——哦，我甚至不打算再说一遍所有这些了。
Thanks to WYPR in Baltimore. Alix Spiegel's story was funded with money from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
感谢巴尔的摩的WYPR。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔的故事由公共广播公司提供资金支持。
This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所（PRX）分发。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who was allowed to visit our program this week. If he would just follow some simple rules--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他获准在本周访问我们的节目。如果他能遵守一些简单的规则——
Not to speak, or stare, or indicate, in any way, that he was anything other than a closeted gay man.
不要发言，不要凝视，或以任何方式表明他除了是一个隐藏的同性恋者之外的任何身份。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。